[Music]
in today's reporters notebook we look at
how we have lost the ability to have an
honest debate and stay respectful I
would like to have an argument by which
I mean I would like to enjoy having an
argument
a brisk exchange of views where
participants are enlivened and learned
something it is still possible there are
pockets of small tribes that still
engage in this behavior though it does
feel very rare what passes for argument
today are the sheared-off exchanges in
social media and the vinegar that is
spooned back and forth on cable news the
Supreme Court depends on good arguments
though the hearing to pick its next
member opened with what felt like a
group drowning you have access to it not
get 80% motives were questioned and
serious issues were responded to with
loud talking very warm when questions
were asked the key to any good argument
the nominee offered the usual peekaboo
responses we pick judges who are to rule
on the quality of arguments through a
process where quality arguments are
smothered bad arguments endanger a
polarized nation you can't understand
why a person kneels at an NFL game or
understand why that offends someone
unless you know how to argue and without
understanding you have conflict a new
book by Greg lukianov and Jonathan Hite
identifies the stakes unless we learn to
argue better we will grow dumber be less
happy and become a nation of grudge
holders so how do you have an argument
treat others like human beings have a
generous interpretation of their views
allow them to clarify before shaming
them don't judge their motive or judge
them by the group they're in if you are
religious follow the first tenant of
every major religion treat others the
way you would like to be treated this
leads to understanding and if that
doesn't happen no one gets sore and
reaches for the fireplace poker to
settle things above all practice
humility follow the maxim when arguing
with a fool
make sure they're not doing the same
thing that's good when arguing with a
fool make sure they're not doing the
same thing but I have to take notes
generous interpretation of their views
yeah I need to work on that part I'm
gonna make sure all of my danksgiving
guests watch this ticket when you mix
argument and family that can be a
particularly difficult challenge to
one's generosity you need to send that
piece over to Washington DC my friend
Nikki that was it in a lot of places